when implementing the deep neural
network one of the debugging tools I
often use to check the correctness of my
code it's a total piece of paper and
just work through the dimensions and
matrix I'm working with so let me show
you how to do that since I hope this
will make it easier for you to implement
your dependences what so capital L is
equal to five and come down quickly
not counting the input layer there are
five layers here so 400 layers and one
output layer and so if you implement
forward propagation the first step will
be Z 1 equals W 1 x equal features X
plus B 1 so let's ignore the on bias
terms B for now and focus on the
parameter W now this first hidden layer
has three hidden units so this is on
layer 0 layer 1 layer 2 layer 3
therefore and there five so using the
notation we had from the previous video
we have the N 1 which is the number of
10 units on layer 1 is equal to 3 and
here we would have 2 n 2 is equal to 5
and 3 is equal to 4 and 4 is equal to 2
and n 5 is equal to 1 and so far we've
only seen your networks with a single
output unit that later in later courses
we'll talk about neural network with
multiple output units as well and
finally for the input layer we also have
and 0 equals and X is equal to 2 so now
let's think about the dimensions of Z W
and X V is the vector of activations for
this first hidden layer so Z is going to
be V by 1 is going to be a 3 dimensional
vector so I'm going to write it as a n1
by 1 dimensional vector and 1 by 1
dimensional matrix is 3 3 by 1 in this
case
now how about the input features X X we
have two input features so X is in this
example two by one but more generally it
will be n 0 by 1 so what we need is for
the matrix w1 to be something that when
we multiply and n 0 by 1 vector to it
begin an one by one vector right so you
have sort of a three dimensional vector
equals something times a 2 dimensional
vector and so by the rules of matrix
multiplication this has got to be a me
by 2 matrix right because the 3 by 2
matrix times a 2 by 1 matrix or times a
2 or one vector that gives you a fee by
one vector
and more generally this is going to be
an N 1 by n 0 dimensional matrix so what
we think about here is that the
dimensions of w1 has to be N 1 by n 0
and more generally the dimensions of WL
must be NF L by n L minus 1 so for
example the dimensions of W 2 for this
it will have to be 5 by 3 or it will be
n 2 by N 1 because we're going to
compute Z 2 as W 2 times a 1 and again
this ignore the bias for now but so this
is going to be 3 by 1 and we need this
to be 5 by 1 and so this had better be 5
by 3 and similarly W 3 will be is really
the dimension of the next layer comma 2
dimension of the previous layer so this
is going to be 4 by 5 w 4
is going to be on 2x4 and w5 is going to
be 1 by 2 okay so the general formula to
check is that when you're implementing
the matrix for a layer L to the
dimension of that matrix B and L by n L
minus 1 now let's think about the
dimension of this vector B this is going
to be a 3 by 1 vector so you have to add
that to another 3 by 1 vector in order
to get a 3 by 1 vector as the output or
in this example you need to add this
this is going to be 5 by 1 so it's going
to be another 5 by 1 vector in order for
you know the sum of these two things
that have in the boxes to be honest L
divided by 1 vector so the more general
rule is that um in the example on the
Left B 1 is N 1 by 1 right that's 3 by 1
and in the second example it is on this
is n 2 by 1 and so the more general case
is that BL should be n L by 1
dimensional so hopefully these two
equations help you to double check that
the dimensions of your matrices W as
well as of your vectors P are the
correct dimensions and of course if
you're implementing back propagation
then the dimensions of DW should be the
same as the dimension of W so DW should
be the same dimension as W and D D
should be the same dimension as B now
the other key set of quantities whose
dimensions to check are these Z X as
well as a of L which we didn't talk
too much about here but because Z eval
is equal to G of a of L apply
element-wise then Z and a should have
the same dimension in these types of
networks now let's see what happens when
you have a vectorized implementation
that looked at multiple examples at a
time even for a vectorized
implementation of course the dimensions
of WB DW and DB will stay the same but
the dimensions of VA as well as X will
change a bit in your vectorized
implementation so previously we had Z 1
equals W 1 times X plus B 1 where this
was n 1 by 1 plus N 1 by M 0 X was n 0
by 1 and B was n 1 by 1 now in a
vectorized implementation you would have
Z 1 equals W 1 times X plus B 1 where
now Z 1 is obtained by taking the Z ones
for the individual example so that z11
z12 up to Z 1 m and stacking them as
follows and this gives you V 1 so the
dimension of V 1 is that instead of
being n1 by 1
it ends up being n1 by M if M is the
size your training set the dimensions of
w1 stays the same cystal and 1 by n 0
and X instead of being n 0 by 1 is now
all your training examples stamped
horizontally so is now n 0 by M and so
you notice that when you take a N 1 by n
0 matrix and multiply that line and 0 by
n matrix that together they
actually give you an N 1 by M
dimensional matrix as expected now the
final detail is that B 1 is still an one
by one but when you take this and add it
to B then through pipes and Broadcasting
this will get duplicated into an N 1 by
M matrix and then added element wise so
on the previous slide we talked about
the dimensions of WB DW and DB here what
we see is that whereas ZL as well as al
are of dimension n L by 1 we have now
instead that capital ZL as well as
capital al are ml by M and a special
case of this is when L is equal to 0 in
which case a 0 which is equal to just
your training set input features X is
going to be equal to n 0 by M as
expected and of course when you're
implementing this in back propagation
we'll see later you end up computing DZ
as well as da and so these will of
course have the same dimension as Z and
a so I hope the exercise went through
house clarified the dimensions of the
various matrices you'll be working with
when you implement back-propagation for
deep neural network so long as you work
through your code and make sure that all
the matrices dimensions are consistent
that will usually help you go some ways
towards eliminating some class of
possible bugs so I hope that exercise
for figure out the dimensions of the
various matrices you'll be working on is
helpful when you implement a deep neural
network if you keep straight the
dimensions of these various matrices and
vectors you're working with hopefully
they'll help you eliminate some cause of
possible bug them it certainly helps me
get my code right
so next we've now seen some of the
mechanics of how to do certain forward
propagation in a neural network but why
are people Network so effective and why
do they do better than shallow
representations let's spend a few
minutes in the next video to discuss